Connie's house wasn't the only thing
that got demolished in a young Sheldon
finale our hearts did too and one scene
in particular had fans sobbing longtime
fans of The Big Bang Theory spin off
young Sheldon though all too well that
the show has no trouble reigning in the
comedy in exchange for heartfelt and
dramatic moments however even they
weren't prepared for what the season six
finale a tornado a 10-hour flight and a
darn fine ring brought them when a
tornado touches down in Texas the shock
of the disaster prompts the scattered
members of the Koopa Clan to reconsider
their interpersonal relationships and
situations there are plenty of emotional
moments from the episode to go around
above viewers are especially struck by
the scene where Cooper Family patriarch
George senior and Missy reconcile over
their recently frayed relationship while
stuck on the side of the road Missy who
has been dealing with quite a bit of
teenage angst lately owns up to her
recent actions while George does his
best to comforter after the episode
aired on May 18 2023 many fans online
were vocal regarding how this scene as
well as the rest of the episode made
them feel as one redditor rose I started
crying when George and Messi were
hugging each other on the side of the
road as it turns out they were far from
the only person who shed some tears
several young Sheldon fans noted that
they were surprised by how much they
reacted emotionally to George and
Missy's bonding scenes and the season 6
finale in general I don't think I've
ever cried at a show like I did with
this one Missy and George bonding moment
was killer and then following it up with
Connie's house being destroyed even fans
who weren't as hot on the overall
episode and its plot lines found the
moment quite compelling one user noted I
really didn't like the use of a tornado
to resolve everyone's feelings after a
fight for a second time but they did it
just as well as the first time I cried
at the end at Connie's house and
George's ability to step in and protect
himself and Missy incredibly endearing
sorry for everything particular praise
was heaped upon Reagan revord's
performance as Missy as fans found her
to be the standout character of the
episode even while fans on Reddit
discussed how much they loved George
senior and Missy's emotional moment
several other parts of the episode came
up in conversation the destruction of
Memo's House and the overall chemistry
of the young Sheldon cast members were
discussed as were the unexpected actions
of the often shady and condescending
Pastor Jeff Difford instead of writing
her route he keeps his lips sealed about
the gambling room me more runs within
her laundromat largely because of the
fate of her home and a traumatic
experience they just endured in the form
of the tornado one Reddit user described
Jeff's and characteristic decision as
one of the highlights of the season 6
finale while another fun feels this was
a rare example of Jeff choosing his
Humanity over his faith still one person
isn't exactly Overjoyed by GF choosing
to look out for me more calling him out
for his inconsistency writing why can't
he forgive the sin of Georgie getting
Mandy pregnant out of wedlock when this
guy's first wife hated him so much and
then left him all in all the closer of
young Sheldon season 6 a tornado a
10-hour flight and a darn fine ring
doesn't seem to have left fans of the
show disappointed
[Music]